republicans generally argue that the u.s
is
not the largest polluter and thus
eliminating pollution within the u.s
isn't as effective as it may seem
conversely
democrats argue that the u.s is
nonetheless a top polluter
and thus reaches at the example by
reducing pollution first
so which country is actually putting out
the most pollution today
and can we ever become a 100
eco-friendly society
well starting off if we take a look at
the co2 emission charts
we will immediately see that the largest
polluter in terms of co2
is in fact china by far as they put out
10.06
gigatons of pollution every single year
that accounts for 28 of global co2 air
pollution
and is the same as 10.06
quadrillion grams of pollution we all
know
that's an insanely large number but when
we're dealing with such
unfathomable numbers we usually don't
understand
how big the number truly is so let's
translate that giant
into more comprehensible numbers if each
gram of pollution was equal to a dollar
china's pollution would be enough to
give every single person
in the entire world 1.25
million dollars every year and even if
you put out
one gram of co2 every single second of
your entire life
it would take you 317 million years
to reach china's annual co2 emissions so
yeah
it's a big number and though the u.s is
far behind china we're not necessarily
good
either the united states puts out 5.41
gigatons of co2 every year which
accounts for about
15 percent of global co2 emissions if
you take a closer look at this chart
you'll quickly see that the top four
global polluters which are china
the us india and russia account for over
half of global co2 emissions at 55
percent
but this doesn't paint the clearest of
pictures as
each of these countries have vastly
different population sizes
so if we transition to co2 emissions per
capita
we'll see that the top polluter is the
oil giant saudi arabia
who comes in at 18.48 tons of co2
per person however with this statistic
the margins aren't nearly as large and
kazakhstan
australia the u.s and canada come in
at nearly the same amount something to
note though is that china
falls down to 13th place in this measure
and
india falls down to 21st place but
even this is not the best way to rank
co2 emissions by country
because each of these countries
radically vary in terms of consumption
sure china and saudi arabia come out on
top
in terms of co2 emissions however the
products that these countries produce
are consumed on a worldwide basis forty
percent of
all worldwide consumer electronics come
from not china and total
but more surprisingly one company in
china
which is foxconn all of your apple dell
amazon hp products and basically half of
every other electronic company you can
think of get some of their components
or their entire products from this one
company in china
and this is perfectly illustrated by
these countries net export figures
china's net exports are positive 426
billion dollars per year
meaning that they produce 426 billion
dollars more
than they consume the us on the other
hand not only has
negative net exports but the most
negative net exports
in the entire world by far we stood
at negative 776 billion dollars in the
exports
in 2017. second place goes to the uk
and they're only about a fifth of the us
at negative 166 billion
now this is not too bad from an
economical standpoint
as the us economy is the largest in the
world
so our net exports in relation to our
gdp
is really not that bad but this is
extraordinarily terrible when it comes
to carbon footprint
as we are the largest net consumers and
a significant proportion of china's
crazy high co2 emissions
can be attributed to us as well as other
western power consumers
as a result if we account for these
consumption discrepancies
the largest air polluter in the world is
likely the u.s
and other western countries such as
canada the uk
and france are likely not that far
behind on a per capita basis
meanwhile the pollution from china
russia
and saudi arabia isn't nearly as bad as
they seem
as a significant amount of their
pollution can actually be attributed to
western countries
with that being said where is all of
this air pollution
even coming from and is it possible to
fix
is it manufacturing or planes or cars or
something else
well the answer is actually electricity
and heat production which accounts for
25 percent
of the global greenhouse gas emissions
and
this is closely followed up by
agriculture forestry
and other land use which comes in at 24
industry accounts for 21 and
transportation
actually only accounts for 14 now
everything we've covered so far sounds
really bad
and politicians often like to bring up
these points in doomsday talks
to try to win over votes don't get me
wrong here
air pollution is a very serious concern
but
what often gets overlooked is all of the
outstanding progress
we have already made since the year 1980
our aggregate emissions according to epa
has decreased by 71 percent
in other words we only put out 29 of the
air pollution
that we put out in 1980 this is despite
a 182
increase in gross domestic product a 114
increase in vehicle miles traveled a 44
increase in population
and a 28 increase in energy consumption
it's frightening to think how much we
were polluting the air in the 1980s
if today is already quite bad on the
bright side
over the last 40 years our economy has
nearly tripled
and we have become power consumers of
energy and manufactured goods
but despite this our aggregate emissions
has nearly quartered
and this is all thanks to innovations in
reducing air pollution
across the board with such great
progress
can we become a 100 eco-friendly society
well unfortunately the answer is no
but we can get well into the 90 range
this isn't to say that we can't
eliminate virtually all air pollution on
the earth
however it's unlikely that we'll get to
zero percent air pollution
on a societal level this is because
certain processes
cannot be transitioned into 100
eco-friendly
if we take a look at each of the top
polluting economic sectors
we'll see that there are portions of
each industry that can't be completely
transitioned
for example as for electricity and heat
production
we can create clean energy using solar
panels wind turbines
and hydro power but at the end of the
day
no matter the path we choose we'll have
to store the energy
in battery cells and of course battery
cell production
causes pollution not to mention we have
to actually manufacture the wind
turbines
the solar panels the motors and so on
and so forth
and this is the same case with
transportation
as well the production of vehicles
themselves as well as the batteries
will continue contributing to air
pollution as for agriculture
the general trend towards organic food
could actually
increase our overall emissions by 21
but that's not accounting for any
improvements in agricultural efficiency
which we have consistently seen over the
past several decades
and finally moving on to the last major
sector
we have industry interestingly the vast
majority of emissions from this sector
are actually from creating energy to run
these facilities
as opposed to the processes that are
actually taking place within these
facilities
thus most of this sector can eventually
be converted to running an electric
as well but this again proposes
pollution from battery cell production
anyways as you can see though we are
able to eliminate the vast majority of
global emissions
by transitioning into clean energy and
increasing efficiency
there will be certain aspects that will
linger on unless we figure out how to
eliminate batteries themselves or
something like that
if this is the case how would it be
possible to eliminate virtually all air
pollution
on earth well the answer may lie in jeff
bezos plan to move heavy industries like
battery production
and energy collection to other planets
but even if that doesn't come to
fruition
we should be able to get 90 plus
eco-friendly
the question though is how long this
will take if we annualize the 71
reduction in emissions over the last 40
years we get an annual decline
of approximately negative 3.05 percent
per year
this number should only accelerate as we
move forward
thanks to the exponential breakthroughs
we are making regarding battery
technology
which will significantly aid in the
transition to clean energy
if we assumed the year 1980 was 100
non-eco-friendly which it was not and
give ourselves a 3
improvement rate per year we should
reach 90
eco friendly in 35 years or about 2055
but of course 1980 was not 100
non-eco-friendly
so a more reasonable estimate would
likely be in the 2040s
especially with exponential battery
advancements
so basically by 2050 at that same rate
we would reach 95 eco-friendly in the
late 2070s
and 97.5 eco-friendly by the end of the
century
and we can work on getting to 100 by
potentially shifting certain industries
off of the earth in the 2100s so
that would be the natural progression
towards a 100 percent
eco-friendly society and that's not too
bad at all
but many liberal politicians want to
accelerate this curve
from 30 to 40 years to just 10 to 20
years
which may be possible given government
mandates and
strict regulation so the question isn't
whether we'll reach a solid 90
plus eco-friendly society as this will
happen
with or without government aid simply
due to innovation
the real question is whether it's worth
rapidly displacing
tens of millions of jobs and hundreds of
businesses
in favor of pushing forward this
timeline by 10 to 20 years
do you guys think the environmental
benefits of moving forward the timeline
by 10 to 20 years
is worth the economic sacrifice comment
that down below
also if you guys appreciate the depth of
this analysis
then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one